You are listening to radio
lab radio from W N Y.
S? Yup.
Okay.
Hey man, how are ya? So Aaron, set
this up. Who are we about to meet?
So this is skip Sherry. He
lives in Brooklyn and that is,
we should say Aaron Scott, he's a
reporter who turned us on to skip.
And Aaron met up with skip because he had
this experience that's common to a lot
of people who moved in New York City.
Just tell us where you, where you grew up.
I grew up in the country
outside of Athens,
Ohio on 54 acres of woodland.
And I would work all day as a kid in the
heat hoeing and picking strawberries,
hauling water, planting trees. He had
planned the woods. I loved the woods.
But as he got older he knew he
couldn't stay in Athens. Why not? Well,
he's a musician. He wanted
to make a living at it.
So he bounced around for a bit.
I finally find them finally at age 30
there was no place to go except for New
York's. It wasn't a matter that
you wanted to live in New York,
New York was your last, my last option.
And he hated it because it was ugly
to me. You know, like, like
which too many humans. Too many.
Too much concrete. Yeah. No.
One theory about autism is that the things
that come into an autistic kids brain
all have equal value. They don't
know how to sort through it.
And when I first came to New
Yorker was, it was really
overwhelming. I had
decided to leave for sure,
but then take us to the roof. I
was lucky when I first moved here.
So he's staying with a friend who lives
in this big building in Brooklyn Heights
right across from the twin towers.
It is 36 stories high and he decides
one lonely night to go up onto the roof.
And there's this intense fog
in the twin towers. The bottom of them
was covering the fog but not the top.
So it was like they were floating.
There's little like a cuticle sliver
of moon in the sky and the foghorns are
going in. The boats are slowly moving.
[inaudible]
and there's this Rees and I had this,
this brass penny listed
that my father had given me,
and I was standing there and I was
playing it and that I was really suddenly
something clicked. I
was like, oh, that must,
those are all the bridges.
That's Williamsburg Bridge.
That's the Manhattan bridge. There's
the Brooklyn Bridge, that's New York.
It's small now.
[inaudible]
and I'm looking at the Statue of Liberty
and my grandmother, Anastasia Pantie,
came from Albania and
they went to Ellis island.
I could see my history there too,
and I was suddenly hit me like,
oh my goodness, this is like a coral
reef. You can't see the people,
but look at this beautiful strip
fog in the air. It was just
the whole city was breathing,
the whole nature was beating.
Everything was [inaudible] breathing.
I felt connected on a spiritual
level to the city for the first time.
[inaudible]
and so skip decided to stay for awhile,
for awhile. All over the world.
People are now moving. Of course,
we know this from the country
to the city at this point.
We'll two years ago across
this extraordinary benchmark
that's physicist Jeff
West,
where more than half of the planet is
now urbanized 51% yet not made us wonder
how do cities work?
Is there some deep organic logic that
holds all these people together or is
writer gentle era puts it.
Our city's just these tumors
that people on the landscape
[inaudible]
I'm Janet. Boom. Ron. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and our topic today,
cities, cities. I loved
it, but I don't know why
[inaudible].
All right, so in talking
about cities, New York City,
it's kind of hard to know where to start
because every city has its own DNA,
kind of its own unique feel.
Yeah.
Like for instance, Oh, let me just
give you my own stupid example here.
So every time I go to St Louis to visit
my mom, yeah, I'm gay, I'm on the plane,
I'm in my own kind of groove and I step
off the plane into the airport and it's
just like with the first step,
you just hit this wall of
something is different.
Like you feel the difference in your
bone because let's the question I,
is he there? Right. I'm here.
What gives the city its feel?
Oh is this Mr Bob Levine?
This is Mr Rob Levin.
Mr Bob Levine is a professor of
psychology, California State University.
And he thinks the answer
to that question is time.
Time did each city warps
time in its own unique way.
My cities are my subjects now.
He studied this idea for the past 30
years in all kinds of different ways.
We looked at things like a
percentage of people wearing watches.
How long does it take bank tellers in
each city to change a $20 bill? Really?
Yeah. And then we, we, we looked
at talking speed offerings. Yeah.
We'd get on the phone and uh,
call post offices since that seemed like
something that would be available every
place and make a standard request.
What'd you tell me the difference
between regular mail certified mail and
insured mail. Okay. Certified as when
you just need someone to sign for it.
Then he says they'd calculate the
number of syllables per second
regular mail. Just close your
mail. You know if it's out of Utah,
Salt Lake City, Utah,
2.73 syllables per second to put group
number three car to come back to your
house. Springfield, mass
[inaudible] 3.4 or five
syllables per second and
certified is when you want a
not really sure where it's from
because the tape lost the ID,
but it could be Nashville
the daily. They want to know
who he wanted return receipt
and if it is national
2.65 syllables per second.
Well Springfield is like fuel,
but the whole talking thing was
just really a prelude for Bob.
It got him into what he,
I think he's most known for and
what we find most fascinating.
We actually looked at
at walking speed lots.
Yeah. Well what I would do is I would
get into a new city and I'm in Mumbai,
India, Jerusalem, CD Chiang Mai, Thailand.
We actually put out a call to radio
lab listeners everywhere in beginner in
Liberia to help us repeat the
study. Hey, good morning Radiolab.
I'm recording from Dublin, Ireland,
downtown Oslo, Copenhagen to a new city.
And step one, I would scope out
main business and shopping books,
top and street step to get out some
street or roll of spring red strings,
two feet long. 20 meters means over
here. We wouldn't say feed really.
Step three, use that string to measure
out the distance. Just have to roll out.
You taped the one end to the sidewalk and
I would just make a more step four and
go undercover. Get into Carter
and uh, it'd be cool, you know,
act like you're in the paper
or waiting for somebody.
I found myself a discreet place.
Found a pretty nice spot here.
You use a stopwatch. I
Richard's a stopwatch. Stopwatch
trusty beef watchers
working. Ready? I'm ready.
Doug. Welcome.
And it know, goes quiet for a minute.
I want to start brilliance. Brilliant.
Still done. This experiment was
actually harder than you would think.
Much harder. I love people.
This is not very easy to do.
Timing was an issue. People
trying to sell you stuff.
I don't need this to show Betty goose
shine. Look in my corner. They just don't,
can't no pitches. Okay,
ready, boom. All together now,
Dodd walk, step, step, step, step, step,
step, step,
Chile. It didn't sound like that
at all. They weren't in sync.
As you can imagine, every
city had its own guard. Step,
step, step, step, step, step, step, step.
We knew but still change
was pretty amazing.
Stop toppling to Oslo.
14.4 seconds. 27 seconds.
You can live area. So
team 0.8 Dwayne is arrows.
12.13 Mexico City, 10.1
seconds. Copenhagen,
21.5 seconds. Yeah,
nine 11.57 Portland and
a half second Jerusalem.
Just to break it down on the high end,
you've got steps, steps on it's step,
step,
step, step, that Dubliner steps. Okay.
She was 9.5 and that's 10.4 who take on
average 10.76 seconds to cover 60 feet.
Compare that to Buchanan. Liberia
step, step, step, step, step.
Let's get around something
that actually owned the head.
She got a teen pink blouse whose Walker's
covered the same distance in about 21
seconds. 21 seconds. So if you want
to think about it in football terms,
by the time the Dubliner has scored a
touchdown, the gripe from you, Kevin,
Liberia is somewhere, I
guess around midfield.
And the spooky thing according to Bob
Levine is if you do these under the same
conditions, same place,
you will get the same time.
These times don't change.
Dublin is always about this steps
you're on. It's steps, steps, steps,
and Buchanan. Liberia is
always around this. Yeah.
Step step.
Yeah. Manhattan is, we
found is right about here.
Usually step with thunder's step,
step, step in pink. No, Dublin,
but not bad. But why the
consistency? What is it?
What is it that makes that walking speed?
Yeah. Where does it come from? You know,
I mean, is anybody beating the drum?
How well can you change the walking speed?
Say a bunch of us got together and decided
that we were just going to up it by
5% on a given day.
Will we get everybody to do it and
will they even notice the difference?
Do we make the city
or just the city make us
thank you to our lockers.
[inaudible] Liberia,
Jerusalem, here are killer man.
And Copenhagen went to Oslo in the
Scott's, Portland, Oregon. Nacho,
Thailand, grand fuller game. [inaudible]
go city [inaudible] in one bay. Mark
from Nolan.
I've Dublin in Ireland perhaps also
to Daniel Estrin and an assessment.
Well done because they didn't,
they didn't say their name so
we put them in there. Okay.
So getting back to that
question I asked a second ago,
why is it that cities develop
particular beats? Yes.
I mean is it because the city does it
to the people or the people do it to the
city? Yeah, and we ran into a
couple of guys who may be released.
Have the start of an answer.
Yes. No, a couple of physicists,
oddly enough high named
Geoffrey West and leash.
This is Jeffery and there's Lewis on
the other side of the table. Cool.
Here at the Santa Fe Institute in New
Mexico and lots of bases and stuff.
Nothing like the cities we just visited.
It's almost biblical in its expanse.
Yeah.
But blue skies just sort of make your
brain potassium and all those good things.
Brave enough, in fact,
to claim from their high desert birch
that these beats the meter of every city
that we've just been to actually
has underneath it a kind of logic.
If you tell me the average
speed of walking in some city x,
take a Rochester,
New York where people walk at about this
60 feet and 12.67 seconds different.
Don't tell him Rochester, you
just tell him the number of beats.
I will tell you the population is
maybe one and a quarter billion people,
actual population,
1.0 3 million people and the
average weight about $16,000 a year.
Actual average wage, $15,588 wow.
But let me ask you a precise question.
Are you 100% correct? Are you
some things you will score close
to a hundred percent other things,
80% but if you start with just the
number of footfalls per unit of time,
they can tell you all kinds of
other things about the same place.
I can tell you how much crime
there is in the city. Income wages,
GDP number college's restaurants,
fancy restaurants, theaters,
police number of patents are being
produced, cultural events per capita,
number of theater that libraries,
the number of aids cases it's
going to have this year. Mainly.
All of these things are
correlated in a quantitative,
and I use the word
predictive fashion. Wait,
are you saying that just from the number
of footsteps per given time that you
can tell? Can you tell me how
many libraries there are? Yes.
Tell me how many hours should expect. Wow.
How many things can you count
when know? Infinite number,
but it's limited by the things
for which there are data.
They've got data from the u s
census, that's Jonah Lehrer.
He's written about Luis and Jeff and
he's the one who kind of got us thinking
about all this pain from Japan,
China data from sociological surveys on
cell phones and when they put all these
numbers together, they discovered a deep
pattern call comes from the footsteps,
not the footsteps.
The footsteps are a reflection of this
deep and fundamental pattern that governs
everything. Just one fact. What
is it you really want to know?
Yeah. What is it? Size, size,
how many people live there?
Size matters.
Size is the largest determinant
of all characteristics of a city,
right? They would say, tell
me the size of the city,
and I can explain the vast majority of
all of these different variables that we
can measure. Right? As a city scales up,
they say 100,000 to 200,000 the million
to 2 million from 5 million to 10
everything about it. All those
things that they'd been measuring,
they scale up too,
but they scale up according to a
very simple mathematical formula.
It does not matter that New York has big
skyscrapers and is on the ocean and the
Boise is in the rocky mountains that
San Francisco is on San Francisco Bay.
Wait a second. Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. That can't be. They can't be.
I was with you right up until
the last to that last point.
I mean you go to the Midwest and it's
landlocked and then you go to a port city
and it's on a part. I mean
that's got to matter. It matters,
but these actually are superficial effects
and account for only 10 20% of their
variation. What they're saying
is that those specificities, the,
the local history is in
large part insignificant,
but it is completely overwhelmed by
these generic laws of urban scaling.
That to me is a very interesting and
surprising idea simply because we don't
think of cities like that at
all. No, we certainly do not.
That's because you're not a physicist
and you don't think abstractly in that
regard. Well, why should
I? Because sometimes it can
be very useful to remember.
What these guys have done is they've
just created eight average profile for
every size city. So if you're a 1
million or 7 million or 12 million,
here's how many things you should
have and all you can all say, okay,
let's look specifically
that city and analysis.
Is it overperforming on the performance?
So what are some cities that are
overperforming for their size?
A of the largest cities? San
Francisco is quite an innovative city.
New York's about average,
about times of patents on terms New
York's below average produces roughly
speaking the number of patents that
should for size. You produce for example,
about uh, twice as many
patents as Boston. We do
[inaudible] you should have produced many
more given the size difference between
about counting patents. I mean who
may, who did, we don't have Ng.
This is one of the problems
with their larger theory,
which is that they're relying on your
data at the u s census collected.
So that's a real blind spot. Fabulous.
If we ever can figure out a way to count.
Fabulous a point you're not taking into
account what it actually the experience
of living in a place. Well, what this,
what a theory cannot do is tell
you about the essence of New York,
the new Yorkness of New York,
so to speak, the soul of the city.
And where does that come from?
I mean, I think that's such
a broad question. Well,
obviously it has something to do with
lots of people being jammed into a tight
space. Firemen bumping into each other,
the kind of people who move there.
What the physicists we
call human friction.
And that's a story you can't really
tell in math, but you can hear it.
Take skip.
He gave producer Aaron Scott a
tour of his block in Brooklyn,
listen to who he bumps into every
day. So he took us on this tour.
First place we went was this Jamaican
body shop. Body shop is in cars. Yeah.
Religion specialists. I mean
it's basically these, you know,
western, these Jamaican guys
listening to reggae Bhutan
and hip hop reggae, no one,
I like all kind of music like someplace
and across across the street from this
is kinder Spiel,
hidden orthodox Jewish cookie
bakery and under pointed from that,
it's a butcher that, um,
sells live goats and chickens
and here are the goats.
And on the corner of
the Spanish Pentecostal church,
every Sunday they give it up to God
with this exceedingly enthusiastic band.
And I huddle at the window
[inaudible]
and I think this is the best
music in the world, right?
Feel that deeply.
[inaudible]
and then across the street
from that one is a mosque.
No,
it was beautiful on the
inside, across the street.
There's this big building
in the proprietor of this
space is a gay foot fetish
film producer. Show me your
feet, show me your feet.
Two 82nd he's got Jamaicans,
Orthodox Jews are the cookies,
Hispanics, Jesus, Allah,
goats in gay porn. Me, your
feet all on the same block.
Absolutely. For me, that's the hammer,
the nails, that's the wrong gradients.
Now I'm gonna take that home and
I'm gonna Assemble it into a song.
And when you heard his music,
could you hear all that stuff?
Some of it is clear than others.
[inaudible]
the sounds of the neighborhood,
like the reg aton music of the
the West indies auto body shops.
He kind of takes them and then filters
it through some device that makes it
sound like,
oddly enough,
the day that Aaron spoke with skip was
the day skip decided he's leaving New
York City and he put in his notice,
which I guess makes his latest album,
sonic New York, kind of a
dear John Letter to the city.
You can hear it on our website,
radio lab.org and Robert Levine's book
for one about walking in time and stuff.
Yeah. It's called the geography of
time. More information about that too,
on our website, radiolab.org also, you
can subscribe to our podcasts there.